next is going to be ally in Kentucky hi
Ally welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
okay thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so my husband and I are
on baby steps eyes and he works in the
building supply industry uh oh he works
for the building supply industry okay
women I think that we had a technical
glitch here let's try again Ali is in
Kentucky okay is that you Ali yeah okay
sorry we had a little glitch down here
in the studio so anyway the your husband
works in the building supply industry
and what yes and so we both decided that
our next home we want to build our
forever home since we kind of have a
unique advantage with his connections
and ability to get supplies pretty low
my blow cost however we have a
difference in opinion on which way to go
about building our home
I am the nerd and he's the free spirit
he wants to sell our house this spring
when the markets hot go ahead and get as
much you know out of our house as
possible and then he wants to build a
smaller more energy-efficient home on a
smaller lot to kind of allow us to have
some savings to have to help propel our
savings for the new home and pay off the
land and then build the house whereas I
would rather just stay put
crack down on our budget and save up
pile up the cash that way and pay off
the land before we built the house we've
got two kids so I personally don't want
to move on twice but he thinks it would
be best to sell our house now to get the
most out of it yeah he's got the itch
bad and and there's no indication that
the real estate market a year from now
is worse than it is now so his theory is
just he just wants to live on this
property
he just got the itch and the problem I
mean you're more than just a nerd free
spirit thing this is more of mama bear
protecting the Cubs and he's got this
wild crazy scheme going and you're
trying to protect the family from that
that's more what's going on in your head
you're trying to not say that out loud
so I said it but I here's what happens
too many times in these situations the
big house never gets built if you move
into the little house on the land and so
I wouldn't do that
I would stay put I'm with you you get my
vote on this and I would just continue
to save money and get yourself in a
position you're home one year from this
spring even two years from the spring is
not going to be worth less than it's
worth now and if it is it'd be a highly
unusual real estate market like
historically almost never happens okay
so you're not gonna go anywhere but up
in value while you're sitting there
saving money yes you do have a monthly
mortgage payment I assume right now
don't you yes we do that's our only
payment yeah which you would not have in
his scenario because you'll be living in
the little property paid for right right
well we well no we wouldn't have it on
the other house of the mortgage or just
be much lower a lot lower than what it
is now because we would have a lot of
equity out of this house to put towards
the small one the temporary move like so
would your standard of living in the
Little House on the Prairie I mean I
think if he was a bachelor this might
work but he's got a wife and two kids we
would go hole up in a basement somewhere
and make it work but with the kids it's
just stressful to move them twice I'll
build a barn living the loft or
something I mean people do that stuff
all the time if they're trying to make
this deal work but but kiddos being drug
around and yeah I answer questions here
like what would I do if I woke up in
your shoes and I would do your plan that
is okay thank you one correction there
are no forever homes true everyone's
life changes everyone's life changes and
what is your dream and meets your needs
now won't be your dream and meet your
needs someday so never build something
that you feel like you have to stay
there forever for it to be a smart
decision it can still be a very
Mart decision he's got access to build
deals on building supplies
he knows the building business you guys
have a good solid plan you could build a
great home on a great property that your
family enjoys for a very long time but
there are very few people that spend
more than 10 or 12 years in a given
house it's very unusual occasionally I
run into somebody spend their their
whole life but it's very unusual hey
thanks for the call